I don't know how to intro this finally
experiencing my third general fantasy of
being in Zack Morris is back oh oh my
god
two girls one prop bed no high minutes
for somebody no no you know you're like
different now
Marianna or in the world what is
restaurant called save by the max it's a
pop-up like art installation is slash
actual functioning restaurant and you're
in Los Angeles and they were about to
leave and so of course
mamrie slid in an Indiana and they have
allowed us to shoot some content here on
the set because you grew up with this
yes I have consider myself a connoisseur
is there a name for the people that are
like like maxinista is not really a
nurse
belly in their belly area we're shooting
a video over a mamie's channel a classic
why dad with a twist
because we're [ __ ] here sometimes and
now we're shooting in Zack Morris
bedroom for my channel because memory is
such a connoisseur of Saved by the Bell
I thought that we play a game called
plot or not
[Music]
last night I'm gonna read them read the
plotlines of certain state by the failed
episode okay and she will have to tell
me if that's an actual plot line or not
I think I might crushed it I think
you're gonna crush this because I also
went through and I read that I kinda
like come up with some that I really I
don't have enough knowledge to even come
up with good enough fake plot lines
we'll see maybe cuz they buy them out
we'll come back and they'll use your
fake plot line that's the one thing I
did think about was like maybe I'm just
good at writing new problems for them
you could tell me if this is plot or not
okay here we go first one miss bliss
starts a foreign exchange pen pal
program with a spoon France for her
students
but when Zach takes it upon himself to
catfish miss list with boat love letters
from the head of the French program
things get hot and heavy miss bliss was
the predecessor to say it by the Bell I
think that's a real box it's not
[Music]
[Music]
Zach decides that screech is in
desperate need of a girlfriend and sets
out finding him love however there isn't
anyone willing so he dresses up as a
girl and goes under date with screech
but has to act fast the screech takes a
liking to him absolutely I think screech
minor makes for a titty jumping Bambi
after Zach makes strict rules for him
screech his only girlfriend on the show
with violet played by Tori Spelling
[Music]
after a failed attempt to buy concert
tickets Zach and the gang fined $5,000
abandoned at the mall but things don't
work out when the gang is chased around
by mobsters in the mall
that's a plot a u2 concert that they
were trying to go to Wow
yeah that's incredible how old you to is
it should have been like when the gang
wants to go to a u2 concert they get
sick and after 4:10 they are better to
leave
it's called vana with mono and I would
hope you would be called pro bono
Zach fails a family heritage
presentation unless he can make it up he
is off the track team his teacher Miss
Wentworth arranges for a tutor for Zach
named chief Henry who happens to be a
Native American not that is a plot about
his own native american heritage but
does not feel like going to the upcoming
track rally when tragedy strikes when
they find that is on a burial ground
ancestors
[Music]
geli gets a job at the max and meets a
mysterious boy named kyle and nickel
garden whose sleight-of-hand tricks win
her over but that can see through this
illusion not
[Music]
my first thought is I hope this is an
episode I've never seen so that there's
some fresh smell for me
Jesse notices the mysterious rash and
goes on a campaign for better health
services at the high school before
finally realizing from Slater that it's
ringworm oh he is a wrestler yes it's a
pot that's not apply what's up mom she's
like you Pig you have a new career thank
you in order for Kelly to go to a George
Michael concert she has the path of
science test
Zacks persuade screeched a tutor Kelly a
ploy which is more for his benefit than
Kelly's but when Kelly and screeches
friendship becomes closer Zack and
Slater become jealous thinking that
screeching Kelly have fallen in love I
know there's one episode where screech
tutors someone and he uses a pyramid of
Barbies to explain like an equation
Cameron Bure which girl is but I'm gonna
put my money on a plot that is apply go
ahead and find to be a pot and roll
[Music]
the gang hurts their chances of winning
the academics championship after causing
a teacher strike so they can go on a ski
trip mmm they stay at a Las field trip
it's applause I bet Jesse wasn't on
board with that oh it was gonna affect
them winning the academic championship
yeah for sure 100%
[Music]
later did dad attempt to spend probably
time together at the mall when they
start fighting about his future again
they stumble onto a competition for a
new truck the last one with their hand
on the truck wins and it becomes a
battle of wills I know that Slater did
occasionally pop heads with his father
his father is of the army ilk and all
litter was a job but also had some real
artistic this to him one episode he
busted out ballet to win Jessie back at
the max thank you remember however I
don't believe Saved by the Bell could
afford the problem a car so I'm going to
say not it is not oh can you imagine I
mean I can see the episode in my head
right angle creator took me 5 minutes
okay maybe I think you won I mean we
sure did I don't want your new skill
they told us the world owes a touch of
the props here and so I fully just put
this on I mean who knows how many other
people have been missing yeah yeah there
we go
can't wait make sure Chris let's check
out baby's channel youdeserveadrink
cause she is fully made sure that this
place deserved a drink and then other
than that subscribe to this YouTube
channel I make videos whenever
Oh turn on your Saved by the Bell
notification hell yeah there we go other
than that I don't know
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]